الطريق الى ارليت الشماليه النيجر معالم
فقد نحو مصادر ثراء
اكثر من 140 الف طن من اليورانيوم مره عبر
هذا الطريق لكن اليه التنميه بطيئه
الدوران في هذه الارجاء
شركه اورانو الفرنسيه تستحوذ على معظم
مناجم يورانيوم النيجر منذ خمسه عقود
وتملك اورانو اكثر من
63% من شركه سمير التي تستغل اهم مناجم
ارليد
من العمله المحليه بل ومن اليورو
كيورانيوم لكن المنطقه لم تستفيد منها حتى
الايتاوات التي يجب ان تكون محرك
الاستثمارات لم تثمر اي تنميه
تختزل مدينه ارليد خيبه اعمال نيجيريين
المعلقه على ما تملكه بلادهم من ثروات
ابناء المدينه يشكون من الفقر والبطاله في
صفوف الشباب
مختار احدها او لا فقد عجز هو ورفاقه عن
ايجاد عمل بديل اثرى تسريحهم من شركه
كوميناك التبعات هي الاخرى لاورانو بعد
وضع حد لنشاطها المنجمي قبل سنتين
ونقلل لم ياها لدينا ولا كهرباء الخدمتان
منقطعتان نعاني حقا هنا لقد وعدونا
بمتابعه امورنا على مدى خمس سنوات ولم
يفعلوا
بعد الفقر تاتي المخاوفه من التبعات
البيئيه والصحيه لنشاط هذه الشركات مؤشرات
منسوب الاشعاعي في محطه النقل التابعه
لشركه سميير لا تبدو مطمئنه على الاطلاق
فمستوى الاشعاعي حسب مختصين يرتفع عشره
اضعاف عن المستوى الطبيعي وسط مدينه ارليد
نخوض معركه ضد تلويث البيئه اذا كان
العاملون في هذه الشركات عرضه للاشعاع فما
ذنب المساكين والاطفال في المدينه دورنا
توعيه الناس وتحذيرهم والضغط على الشركات
لمعالجه ما تسببت فيه من ماس وتذكير
الحكومه بالممارسات السليمه في مجال
البيئه
ومع توقف في سلاسل الامداد يهدد نقص بعض
المواد بشد الانتاج فعليا في سبع اهم منجم
لليورانيومي في العالم
انتاج تعتمد عليه المعامل النوويه
الفرنسيه وفق بعض التقديرات بنسبه 70%
يتواصل استخراج اليورانيوم هنا منذ بدايه
السبعينيات وتؤكد عمليات المسح والتنقيب
ان منطقه صحراء تعد بالمزيد ضربات لم تمكن
هذه الارض وسكانها من تحقيق ما يطمحون
اليه من رفاهيه حتى الان باب الحرمان
الجزيره